yeah so thank you very much for the
introduction so today I'll speak about
deep learning especially in the context
of computer vision so you saw in the
previous talk is neural networks so you
saw the neural networks are organized
into these layers fully connected layers
where neurons in one layer are not
connected but they're connected fully to
all the neurons in the previous layer
and we saw that basically we have this
layer wise structure from input until
output and there are neurons and
nonlinearities etc now so far we have
not made too many assumptions about the
inputs so in particular here we just
assume that an input is some kind of a
vector of numbers that we plug into this
neural network so that both a bug and a
feature to some extent because in most
in most real-world applications we
actually can make some assumptions about
the input that make learning much more
efficient learning much more efficient
so in particular usually we don't just
want to plug in into neural networks
vectors of numbers but they actually
have some kind of a structure so we
don't have vectors of numbers but these
numbers are arranged in some kind of a
layout like an N dimensional array of
numbers so for example spectrograms are
two dimensional arrays of numbers images
are three dimensional arrays of numbers
videos would be four dimensional arrays
of numbers text you could treat as one
dimensional array of numbers and so
whenever you have this kind of local
connectivity structure in your data then
you'd like to take advantage of it and
convolutional neural networks allow you
to do that
so before I dive into commercial neural
networks and all the details of the
architectures I'd like to briefly talk
about a bit of the history of how this
field evolved over time so I like to
start off usually with talking about
Hubble and Wiesel and the experiments
that they performed in 1960s so what
they were doing is trying to study the
computations that happen in the early
visual cortex areas of a cat and so they
had cat and they plugged in electrodes
that could record from the different
neurons and then they showed the cat
different patterns of light and they
were trying to debug a neurons
effectively and try to show them
different patterns and see what they
responded to and a lot of these
experiments inspired some of the
modeling that came in afterwards so in
particular one of the early models that
try to take advantage of some of the
results of these experiments where the
was the model called Newark cockney
truant from Fukushima in 1980s and so
what you saw here was these this
architecture that again is layer wise
similar to what you see in the cortex
where you have these simple and complex
cells where the simple cells detect
small things in the visual field and
then you have this local connectivity
pattern and the simple and complex cells
alternate in this layered architecture
throughout and so this was this looks a
bit like a comm net because you have
some of its features like say the local
connectivity but at the time this was
not trained with backpropagation these
were specific heuristic Allah chose in'
updates that and this was unsupervised
learning back then so the first time
that we've actually used back
propagation to train some of these
networks was an experiment of a young
lagoon in the 1990s and so this is an
example of one of the networks that was
developed back then in 1990s by anne
lagoon as lina at five and this is what
you would recognize today as a
convolutional neural network so it has a
lot of the very simple computational
layers and it's alternating and it's a
similar kind of design to what you would
see in the Fukushima's new york cognate
Ron but this was actually trained with
backpropagation and to end using
supervised learning now so this happened
in roughly 1990s and we're here in 2016
basically about 20 years later now
computer vision has has for a long time
kind of worked here on larger images and
a lot of these models back then were
applied to very small kind of settings
like say recognizing digits in zip codes
and things like that
and they were very successful in those
domains but back at least when I entered
computer vision roughly 2011 it was
thought that a lot of people were aware
of these models but it was thought that
they would not scale up naively into
large complex images that they would be
constrained to these toy tasks for a
long time or I shouldn't say toy because
these were very important tasks but
certainly like smaller visual
recognition problems and so in computer
vision in roughly 2011 it was much more
common to use a kind of these feature
based approaches at the time and they
didn't work essentially that well so
when I entered my PhD in 2011 working on
computer vision you would run a state of
the art object detector on this image
and you might get something like this
where cars were detected in trees and
you would kind of just shrug your
shoulders and say well that just happens
sometimes you kind of just accept it as
a as a something that would just happen
and of course this is a caricature
things actually worked like relatively
decent I should say but definitely there
were many mistakes that you would not
see today about four years nian 2016
five years later and so a lot of
computer vision kind of looked much more
like this when you look into a paper of
trying that try to do image
classification you would find this
section in the paper on the features
that they used so this is one page of
features and so they would use yeah a
gist hog etc and then the second page of
features and all their hyper parameters
so all kinds of different histograms and
you would extract this kitchen sink of
features and a third page here and so
you end up with this very large complex
code base because some of these feature
types are implemented in MATLAB some of
them in Python some of them in C++ and
you end up with this large code base of
extracting all these features caching
them and then eventually plugging them
into linear classifiers to do some kind
of visual recognition tasks so it was
quite unwieldy but it worked to some
extent but they were definitely a room
for improvement and so a lot of this
change in computer vision in 2012 with
this paper from Astrid chef Sookie Ilya
sutskever and Geoff Hinton
so this is the first time that someone
took a convolutional neural network that
is very similar to the one that you saw
in from 1998 from Jana Kuhn and I'll go
into details of how they defer exactly
but they took that kind of network they
scaled it up they made it much bigger
and they trained it on a much bigger
data set on GPUs and things basically
ended up working extremely well and this
is the first time the computer vision
community has really noticed these
models and adopted them to work on
larger images so we saw that the
performance of these models has improved
drastically here we are looking at the
image net eyeless VRC visual recognition
challenge over the years and we're
looking at the top 5 error so low is
good and you can see that from 2010 in
the beginning these were feature based
methods and then in 2012 we had this
huge jump in performance and that was
due to the first kind of convolutional
neural network in 2012 and then we've
managed to push that over time and now
we're down to about 3.5 7% I think the
results for image 2
thousand imagenet challenge 2016 are
actually due to come out today but I
don't think that actually they've come
out yet I have this second tab here
opened I was waiting for the result but
I don't think this is a Pia tiah okay no
nothing
alright well we'll get to find out very
soon what happens right here so I'm very
excited to see that just to put this in
context by the way because you're just
looking at numbers like three point five
seven how good is that that's actually
really really good
so what something that I did about two
years ago now now is that I try to
measure the human accuracy on this data
set and so what I did for that is I
developed this web interface where I
would show myself image net images from
the test set and then I had this
interface here where I would have all
the different classes of image net
there's 1,000 of them and some example
images and then basically you go down
this list and you scroll for a long time
and you find what class you think that
image might be and then I competed
against the ComNet at the time and this
was Google net in 2000 in 2014 and so
hot dog is a very simple class you can
do that quite easily but why is the
accuracy not 0% it well some of the
things like hot dog seems very easy why
isn't it trivial for humans to see well
it turns out that some of the images in
a test set of image net are actually
mislabeled but also some of the images
are just very difficult to guess so in
particular if you have this Terrier
there's 50 different types of terriers
and it turns out to be very difficult
task to find exactly which type of
Terrier that is you can spend minutes
trying to find it turns out that good
convolutional neural networks are
actually extremely good at this and so
this is where I would lose points
compared to ComNet so I estimate that
human accuracy based on this is roughly
2 to 5 percent range depending on how
much time you have and how much
expertise you have and how many people
you involve and how much they really
want to do this which is not too much
and so really we're doing extremely well
and so we're down to 3 percent and I
think the error rate if I remember
correctly was about 1.5 percent so if we
get below 1.5 percent I would be
extremely suspicious on image net that
seems wrong so to summarize basically
what we've done is before 2012 computer
somewhat like this where we had these
feature extractors and then we trained a
small portion at the end of the feature
extractor extraction step and so we only
trained this last piece on top of these
features that were fixed and we
basically replaced the feature extractor
in step with a single convolutional
neural network and now we trained
everything completely end-to-end and
this turns out to work quite nicely so
I'm going to go into details of how this
works in a bit also in terms of code
complexity we kind of went from a setup
that looks whoops
way ahead okay we went from a setup that
looks something like that and papers to
something like you know instead of
extracting all these things we just say
applied 20 layers with three by three
column or something like that and things
work quite well this is of course an
over-exaggeration but I think it's a
correct first order statement to make is
that we've definitely seen that we've
reduced code complexity quite a lot
because these architectures are so
homogeneous compared to what we've done
before so it's also remarkable that so
we had this reduction in complexity we
had this amazing performance on imagenet
one other thing that was quite amazing
about the results in 2012 that is also a
separate thing that did not have to be
the case is that the features that you
learn by training on image that turned
out to be quite generic and you can
apply them in different settings so in
other words this transfer learning works
extremely well and of course I didn't go
into details of convolutional networks
yet but we start with an image and we
have a sequence of layers just like in a
normal neural network and at the end we
have a classifier and when you pre train
this network on image net then it turns
out that the features that you learn in
the middle are actually transferable and
you can use them on different data sets
and that this works extremely well and
so that didn't have to be the case you
might imagine that you could have a
convolutional network that works
extremely well on image net but when you
try to run it on some something else
like birds data set or something that it
might just not work well but that is not
the case and that's a very interesting
finding in my opinion so people notice
this back in roughly 2013 after the
first convolution networks they noticed
that you can actually take many computer
vision datasets and it used to be that
you would compete on all of these kind
of separately and design features maybe
for some of these separately and you can
just shortcut all those steps that we
had designed and you can just take these
pre trained features that you get from
imagenet and you can just train a linear
classifier on every single data set on
top of those features and you up
many state-of-the-art results across
many different data sets and so this was
quite a remarkable finding back then I
believe so things worked very well an
image net Thanks transferred very well
and the code complexity of course got
much much more manageable so now all
this power is actually available to you
with very few lines of code if you want
to just use a convolutional network on
images it turns out to be only a few
lines of code if you use for example
Karis is one of the deep learning
libraries that I'm going to go into and
I'll mention again later in the talk but
basically just load a state-of-the-art
complex all neural network you take an
image you load it and you compute your
predictions and it tells you that this
is an African elephant inside that image
and this took a couple couple hundred or
a couple ten milliseconds if you have a
GPU and so everything does much faster
much simpler works really well transfers
really well so this was really a huge
advance in computer vision and so as a
result of all these nice properties
commnets today are everywhere so here's
a collection of some of the some of the
things I try to find across across
different applications so for example
you can search google photos for
different types of categories like in
this case rubik's cube you can find
house numbers very efficiently you can
of course this is very relevant in
self-driving cars and we're doing
perception in the cars accomplishable
networks are very relevant they're
medical image diagnosis recognizing
Chinese characters doing all kinds of
medical segmentation tasks quite random
tasks like wail recognition and more
generally many tackle challenges
satellite image analysis recognizing
different types of galaxies you may have
seen recently that a wave net from
deepmind also very interesting paper
that they generate music and they
generate speech and so this is a
generative model and that's also just a
comm that is doing most of the heavy
lifting here so it's a convolutional
network on top of sound and other tasks
like image captioning in the context of
reinforcement learning and agent in
environment interactions we've also seen
a lot of advances of using commnets as
the core computational building block so
when you want to play Atari games or you
want to play alphago or doom or
Starcraft or if you want to get robots
to perform interesting manipulation
tasks all of this users come that's as a
core computational
block to do very impressive things not
only are we using it for a lot of
different application we're also finding
uses in art so so here are some examples
from deep dreams so you can basically
simulate what it looks like what it
feels like maybe to be on some drugs so
you can take images and you can just
loosen it features these income that's
or you might be familiar with neural
style which allows you to take arbitrary
images and transfer arbitrary styles of
different paintings like Van Gogh on top
of them and this is all using
convolutional networks the last thing
I'd like to note that I find also
interesting is that in the process of
trying to develop better computer vision
architectures and trying to basically
optimize for performance on the image
net challenge we've actually ended up
converging to something that potentially
might function something like your
visual cortex in some ways and so these
are some of the experiments that I find
interesting where they've studied
macaque monkeys and they record from a
subpopulation of the of the i.t cortex
this is the part that does a lot of
object recognition and so they record so
basically they take a monkey and they
take a ComNet and they show them images
and then you look at what those images
are represented at the end of this
network so inside the monkey's brain or
on top of your convolutional network as
we look at representations of different
images and then it turns out that
there's a mapping between those two
spaces that actually seems to indicate
to some extent that some of the things
we're doing somehow ended up converging
to something that the brain could be
doing as well in the visual cortex so
that's just some intro I'm now going to
dive into convolutional networks and try
to explain the briefly how these
networks work of course there's an
entire class on this that I taught which
is a convolutional networks class and so
I'm going to distill some of you know
those 13 lectures into one lecture so
we'll see how that goes I won't cover
everything of course
okay so convolutional neural network is
really just a single function it goes
from it's a function from the raw pixels
of some kind of an image so we take 224
by 224 by 3 image so 3 here is for the
color channels RGB you take the raw
pixels you put it through this function
and you get 1000 numbers at the end in
the case of image classification if
you're trying to categorize images into
1000 different classes and really
functionally all that's happening in a
convolutional net work is just dot
products
and max operations that's everything but
they're wired up together in interesting
ways so that you are basically doing
visual recognition and in particular the
this function f has a lot of knobs in it
so these w's here that participate in
these dot products and in these
convolutions and fully connected layers
and so on these WS are all parameters of
this network so normally you might have
about on the order of 10 million
parameters and those are basically knobs
that change this function and so we'd
like to change those knobs of course so
that when you put images through that
function you get probabilities that are
consistent with your training data and
so that gives us a lot to tune and turns
out that we can do that tuning
automatically with back propagation
through that search process now more
concretely accomplish on your network is
made up of a sequence of layers just as
in a case of normal neural networks but
we have different types of layers that
we play with so we have convolutional
layers here I'm using rectified linear
unit relu for short as a non-linearity
so I'm making that and explicit its own
layer
pooling layers and fully connected
layers the core computational building
block of a convolutional network though
is this convolutional layer and we have
nonlinearities interspersed we are
probably getting rid of things like
pooling layers we might see them
slightly going away over time and fully
connected layers can actually be
represented there are basically
equivalent to convolutional layers as
well and so really it's just a sequence
of complex in the simplest case so let
me explain convolutional layer because
that's the core computational building
block here that does all the heavy
lifting so the entire comm that is this
collection of layers and these layers
don't function over vectors so they
don't transform vectors as a normal
neural network but they function over
volumes so a layer will take a volume a
three-dimensional volume of numbers an
array in this case for example we have a
32 by 32 by 3 image so those three
dimensions are the width height and I'll
refer to the third dimension as depth we
have three channels that's not to be
confused with the depth of a network
which is the number of layers in that
network so this is just depth of a
volume so this complex layer accepts a
three dimensional volume and it produces
a three dimensional volume using some
weights so the way it actually produces
this output volume is as follows we're
going to have these filters in a
convolutional layer
so these filters are always small
patiently like say for example five by
five filter but their depth extends
always through the input depth of the
input volume so since the input volume
has three channels the depth is 3 then
our filters will always match that
number so we have depth of 3 in our
filters as well and then we can take
those filters and we can basically
convolve them with the input volume so
what that amounts to is we take this
filter oh yeah so that's just the point
that the channels here must match we
take that filter and we slide it through
all spatial positions of the input
volume and along the way as we're
sliding this filter we're computing dot
products so W transpose X plus B where W
are the filters and X is a small piece
of the input volume and B is offset and
so this is basically the convolutional
operation you're taking this filter and
you're sliding it through at all spatial
positions and you're computing that
products so when you do this you end up
with this activation map so in this case
we get a 28 by 28 activate activation
map 28 comes from the fact that there
are 28 unique positions to place this
5x5 filter into this 3 32 by 32 space so
there are 28 by 28 unique positions you
can place that filter in and every one
of those you're going to get a single
number of how well that filter alikes
that part of the input so that carves
out a single activation map and now in a
compositional layer we don't just have a
single filter but we're going to have an
entire set of filters so here's another
filter a green filter we're going to
slide it through the input volume it has
its own parameters so these there are 75
numbers here that basically make up a
filter there are different 75 numbers we
convolve them through get a new
activation map and we continue doing
this for all the filters in that
convolutional layer so for example if we
had six filters in this convolutional
layer then we might end up with 28 by 28
activation maps six times and we stock
them along the depth dimension to arrive
at the output volume of 28 by 28 by 6
and so really what we've done is we've
we represented the original image which
is 32 by 32 by 3 into a kind of a new
image that is 28 by 28 by 6 where this
image basically has these 6 channels
that tell you how well every filter
matches or likes every part of the input
so let's compare this operation to say
using fully connected layer as you would
in a normal neural network
so in particular we saw that we process
the 32 by 32 by 3 volume into 28 by 28
by 6 volume and one question might want
to ask is how many parameters would this
require if we wanted a fully connected
layer of the same number of output
neurons here so we wanted 28 by 28 by 6
or times 20 times when it's 12 times 28
times 6 number of neurons fully
connected how many parameters would that
be turns out that that would be quite a
few parameters right because every
single neuron in the output volume would
be fully connected to all of the 32 by
32 by 3 numbers here so basically every
one of those - 28 by 28 by 6 now
Newell's is connected to 32 by 3 2 by 3
turns out to be about 15 million
parameters and also on that order of
number of multiplies so you're doing a
lot of compute and you're introducing a
huge amount of parameters into your
network now since we're doing
convolution instead you'll notice that
think about a number of parameters that
we've introduced with this example
convolutional layer so we've used we had
6 filters and every one of them was a 5
by 5 by 3 filter so basically we just
have 5 by 5 by 3 filters we have 6 of
them if you just multiply that out we
have 450 parameters and in this I'm not
counting the biases I'm just counting
the raw weights so compared to 15
million we've only introduced very few
parameters also how many multiplies have
we done so computationally how many
flops
are we doing well we have twenty by
twenty eight by six outputs to produce
and every one of these numbers is a
function of a five by five by three
region in the original image so
basically we have 20 by 20 by 6 and then
there's every one of them is computed by
doing 5 times 5 times 3 multiplies so
you end up with only on the order of
350,000 multiplies so we've reduced from
15 million to quite a few so we're doing
less flops and we're using fewer
parameters and really what we've done
here is we've made assumptions right so
we've made the assumption that because
the fully connected layer if this wasn't
fully connected layer could compute the
exact same thing but it would so
specific setting of those 15 million
parameters would actually produce the
exact output of this convolutional layer
but we've done it much more efficiently
we've done that by
reducing these biases so in particular
we've made assumptions we've assumed for
example that since we have these fixed
filters that we're sliding across space
we've assumed that if there's some
interesting feature that you'd like to
detect in one part of the image like say
top left then that feature will also be
useful somewhere else like on the bottom
right because we fix these filters and
apply them at all the spatial positions
equally you might notice that this is
not always something that you might want
for example if you're getting inputs
that are centered face images and you're
doing some kind of a face recognition
isn't like that then you might expect
that you might want different filters at
different spatial positions like say for
I region so you might want to have some
I like filters and for math region you
might want to have mouth specific
features and so on and so in that case
you might not want to use convolutional
layer because those features have to be
shared across all spatial positions and
the second assumptions that we made is
that these filters are small locally and
so we don't have global connectivity we
have this local connectivity but that's
okay because we end up stacking up these
convolutional layers in sequence and so
this the neurons at the end of the
ComNet will grow their receptive field
as you stack these convolutional layers
on top of each other so at the end of
the combat those neurons end up being a
function of the entire image eventually
so just to give an idea about what these
activation maps look like concretely
here's an example of an image on the top
left this is a part of a car I believe
and we have these different filters at
we have 32 different small filters here
and so if we were to convolve these
filters with this image we end up with
these activation labs so this filter if
you convolve it you get this activation
lab and so on so this one for example
has some orange stuff in it so when we
convolve with this image you see that
this white here is denying the fact that
that filter matches that part of the
image quite well and so we get these
activation maps you stack them up and
then that goes into the next
convolutional layer so the way this
looks then looks like then is that we
processed this with some kind of a
convolutional layer we get some output
we apply a rectified linear units some
kind of a non-linearity as normal and
then we would just repeat that operation
so we keep plugging these values into
the next convolutional layer and so they
plug into each other in sequence okay
and so we end up processing the image
over time so that's the convolutional
layer and you'll notice that there are a
few more layers so in particular the
pooling layer i'll explain very
briefly pooling layer is quite simple if
you've used Photoshop or something like
that you've taken a large image and
you've resized it you downsampled the
image
well pulling layers do basically
something exactly like that but they're
doing it on every single channel
independently so for every one of these
channels independently in a input volume
will pluck out that activation lab will
down sample it and that becomes a
channel in the output volume so it's
really down sampling operation on these
volumes so for example one of the common
ways of doing this in the context of
neural networks especially is to use
maximum operation so in this case it
would be common to say for example use
two by two filters stride to so and do
max operation so if this is an input
channel in a volume then we're basically
what that amounts to is we're truncating
it into these two by two regions and
we're taking a max over four numbers to
produce one piece of the output okay so
this is a very cheap operation that down
samples your volumes it's really a way
to control the capacity of the network
so you don't want too many numbers you
don't want things to be too
computationally expensive it turns out
that a pooling layer allows you to down
sample your volumes you're going to end
up doing less computation and it turns
out to not hurt the performance too much
so we use them basically as a way of
controlling the capacity of these
networks and the last layer that I want
to briefly mention of course is the
fully connected layer which is exactly
as what you're familiar with so we have
these volumes throughout as we process
the image at the end you're left with
this volume and now you'd like to
predict some classes so we do is we just
take that volume we stretch it out into
a single column and then we apply for
the connected layer which is really
amounts to just a matrix multiplication
and then that gives us probabilities
after applying like a soft Max or
something like that
so let me now show you briefly a demo of
what the convolutional Network looks
like so this is common nsj this is a
deep learning library for training
convolutional neural networks that I've
that is implemented in JavaScript I
wrote this maybe two years ago at this
point so here what we're doing is we're
training a convolutional network on the
c 410 dataset see 410 is a data set of
50,000 images each image is 32 by 32 by
3 and there are different ten different
classes so here we are training this
network in the browser and you can
the loss is decreasing which means that
we're better classifying these inputs
and so here's the network specification
which you can play with because this is
all done in the browser so you can just
change this and play with this so this
is an input image and this convolutional
network I'm showing here all the
intermediate activations and all the
intermediate basically activation maps
that we're producing so here we have a
set of filters
we're convolving them with the image and
getting all these activation maps I'm
also showing the gradients but I don't
want to dwell on that too much then your
threshold so rel will do anything below
zero gets clamped at zero and then you
pull so this is just down sampling
operation and then another convolution
relu pool compre loophole etc until at
the end we have a fully connected layer
and then we have our soft max so that we
get probabilities out and then we apply
a loss to those probabilities and back
propagate and so here we see that I've
been training in this tab for the last
maybe 30 seconds or one minute and we're
already getting about 30 percent
accuracy on C for ten so this these are
test images from C for ten and these are
the outputs of this compositional
network and you can see that it learned
that this is already a car or something
like that so this trains pretty quickly
in JavaScript so you can play with this
and continue the architecture and so on
another thing I'd like to show you is
this video because it gives you again
this like very intuitive visceral
feeling of exactly what this is
computing is there's a very good video
by Jason Kaczynski from recent advance
I'm going to play this in a bit this is
from the deep visualization tool box so
you can download this code and you can
play with this it's this interactive
convolutional network demo this is
neural networks have enabled computers
to better see and understand the world
they can recognize good buses and zip
top left corner we showed you in this
case kappa hi Daddy so what we're seeing
here is these are activation laps in
some particular shown in real time as
this demo is running so these are for
the calm one layer of an Alex net which
we're going to go into in much more
detail but these are the different
activation maps that are being produced
at this point neural network called Alex
net running in cafe by interacting with
the network we can see what some of the
neurons
for example on this first leg the unit
in the center responds strongly to light
to dark edges its neighbor one neuron
over responds to edges in the opposite
direction dark to light using
optimization we can synthetically
produce images that light up each neuron
on this layer to see what each neuron is
looking for we can scroll through every
layer in the network to see what it does
including convolution pooling and
normalization layers we can switch back
and forth between showing the actual
activations and showing images
synthesized to produce high activation
but the time you get to the fifth
convolutional layer the features being
computed represent abstract concepts for
example this neuron seems to respond to
phases we can further investigate this
neuron by showing a few different types
of information first we can artificially
create optimized images using new
regularization techniques that are
described in our paper these synthetic
images show that this neuron fire is in
response to a face and shoulders we can
also plot the images from the training
set that activate this neuron the most
as well as pixels from those images most
responsible for the high activations
computed via the D combination technique
this feature responds to multiple faces
in different locations and by looking at
the D cons we can see that it would
respond more strongly if we had even
darker eyes and rosy lips we can also
confirm that it cares about the head and
shoulders that ignores the arms and
torso
we can even see that it fires to some
extent for cat faces using back prop or
decom we can see that this unit depends
most strongly on a couple units in the
previous layer con four and on about a
dozen or so in con 3 now let's look at
another neuron on this layer so what's
this unit doing from the top 9 images we
might conclude that it fires 4 different
types of clothing but examining the
synthetic images shows that it may be
detecting not clothing
say but wrinkles in the live plot we can
see that it's activated by my shirt and
smoothing out half of my shirt causes
that hack of the activations to decrease
finally here's another interesting memo
this one has learned to look for printed
text in a variety of sizes colors and
fonts this is pretty cool because we
never asked the network to look for
wrinkles or text or faces the only
papers were provided were at the very
last layer so the only reason the
network learned features like text and
faces in the middle was to support final
decisions at that last layer for example
the text detector may provide good
evidence that a rectangle is in fact a
book seen on edge and detecting many
books next to each other might be a good
way of detecting a bookcase which was
one of the categories we trained the net
to recognize in this video we've shown
some of the features of the deep is
toolbox okay so I encourage you to play
with that it's really fun so I hope that
gives you an idea about exactly what's
going on there at these convolutional
layers we downsample them from what from
time to time there's usually some fully
connected layers at the end but mostly
it's just these convolutional operations
stacked on top of each other so what I'd
like to do now is I'll dive into some
details of how these architectures are
actually put together the way I'll do
this is I'll go over all the winners of
the imagenet challenges and I'll tell
you about the architectures how they
came about how they differ and so you'll
get a concrete idea about what these
architectures look like in practice so
we'll start off with the Alex net in
2012 so the Alex net just to give you an
idea about the sizes of these networks
and the images that they process it took
to 27 by 220 7 by 3 images and the first
layer of an Alex net for example was a
completion layer that had 11 by 11
filters applied with a stride of four
and there are 96 of them stride of four
I didn't fully explain because I wanted
to save some time but intuitively it
just means that as you're sliding this
filter across the input you don't have
to slide in one pixel at a time but you
can actually jump a few pixels at a time
so we have 11 by 11 filters with a
stride a skip of four and we have 96 of
them you can try to compute for example
what is the output volume if you apply
this this sort of convolutional layer on
top of this volume and I didn't go into
details of how you compute that
but basically there are formulas for
this and you can look into details in
the class but you arrive at 55 by 55 by
96 volume as output the total number of
parameters in this layer we have 96
filters every one of them is 11 by 11 by
3 because that's the input depth of
these images so basically just amounts
to 11 but times 11 times 3 and then you
have 96 filters so about 35,000
parameters in this very first layer then
the second layer of an Alex net is a
pooling layer so we apply three by three
filters at Stride of two and they do max
pooling so you can again compute the
output volume size of that after
applying this to that volume and you
arrive if you do some very simple
arithmetic there you arrive at 27 by 27
by 96 so this is the down sampling
operation you can think about what is
the number of parameters and this
pooling layer and of course it's zero so
pooling layers compute a fixed function
fixed down sampling operation there are
no parameters involved in pulling a
layer all the parameters are in
convolutional layers and the fully
connected layers which are some extent
equivalent to convolutional layers so
you can go ahead and just basically
based on the description in the paper
although is non-trivial I think based on
the description of this particular paper
but you can go ahead and decipher what
the volumes are throughout you can look
at the kind of patterns that emerge in
terms of how you actually increase
number of filters in higher
convolutional layers so we started off
with 96 then we go to 256 filters then
to 384 and eventually 4096 units click
on layers you'll see also normalization
layers here which have since become
slightly deprecated it's not very common
to use the normalization layers that
were used at the time for the election
architecture what's interesting to note
is how this differs from the 1998 Iyanla
cool network so in particular
I usually like to think about for things
that hold back progress so at least in a
deep learning so the data is a
constraint compute and then I like to
differentially differentiate between
algorithms and infrastructure algorithms
being something that feels like research
and infrastructure being something that
feels like a lot of engineering has to
happen and so in particular we've had
progress in all those four fronts so we
see that in 1998
the data you could get ahold of maybe
would be on the order of a few thousand
whereas now we have a few million so we
had three orders of magnitude of
increase in number of data compute GPUs
have become available and we use them to
train these networks they are about say
roughly 20 times faster than CPUs and
then of course CPUs we have today are
much much faster than CPUs that they
have back in 1998 so I don't know
exactly to what that works out to but I
wouldn't be surprised if it's again on
the order of three orders of magnitude
of improvement again I'd like to
actually skip over algorithm and talk
about infrastructure so in this case
we're talking about Nvidia releasing the
cuda library that allows you to
efficiently create all these matrix
vector operations and apply them on
arrays of numbers so that's a piece of
software that you rely on and that we
take advantage of that wasn't available
before and finally algorithms is kind of
an interesting one because there's been
in those 20 years there's been much less
improvement in an algorithms than all
these other three pieces so in
particular what we've done with the 1998
network is we've made it bigger so you
have more channels you have more layers
by bit and the two really new things
algorithmically are dropout and
rectified linear units so dropout is a
regularization technique developed by
geoff hinton and colleagues and
rectified linear units are these
nonlinearities that train much faster
than sigmoids and ten HS and this paper
actually had a plot that showed that the
rectified linear units trained a bit
faster than sigmoids and that's
intuitively because of the vanishing
gradient problems and when you have very
deep networks with sigmoids those
gradients banish as Hugh was talking
about in last lecture so what's
interesting also to note by the way is
that both drop out and relu are
basically like one line or two lines of
code to change so it's about two line
diff total in those twenty years and
both of them consist of setting things
to zero so with the relevance of things
to zero when they're lower than zero and
with dropout you set things to zero at
random so it's a good idea to set things
to zero apparently that's what we
learned so if you try to find a new cool
algorithm look for one line dips that
set something to zero probably will work
better and we could add you here to this
list now some of the newest things that
happened some of the
comparing it again and giving you an
idea about the hyper parameters that are
in this architecture it was the first
use of rectified linear units we haven't
seen that as much before this network
using the normalization layers which are
not used anymore
at least in a specific way that they use
them in this paper they used heavy data
augmentation so you don't only put in
you don't only pipe these images into
the networks exactly as they come from
the data set but you jitter them
spatially around a bit and you work them
and you change the colors a bit and you
just do this randomly because you're
trying to build in some invariances to
these small perturbations and you're
basically hallucinating additional data
it was the first real use of drop out
and roughly you see standard hyper
parameters like say batch sizes of
roughly 128 using stochastic gradient
descent with momentum usually point nine
in the momentum learning rates of 1e
negative two you reduce them in normal
ways so you're reduced roughly by factor
of ten whenever validation stops
improving and weight decay of just a bit
five you negative four and ensemble
so you train seven independent
commercial networks separately and then
you just average their predictions
always gives you additional 2%
improvement so this is Alex net the
winner of 2012 in 2013 the winner was
the Z F net this was developed by
Matthew Siler and Rob progress in 2013
and this was an improvement on top of
Alex net architecture in particular one
of the bigger differences here where
that the convolutional layer the first
convolutional layer they went from 11 by
11 stride four to seven by seven strike
two so if slightly smaller filters and
you apply them more densely and then
also they notice that these
convolutional layers in the middle if
you make them larger if you scale them
up then you actually gain performance so
they managed to improve a tiny bit
matthew Zeiler then went he became the
founder of clarify and he worked on this
a bit more inside clarify and he managed
to push the performance to 11% which was
the winning entry at the time but we
don't actually know what gets you from
14% to 11% because Matthew never
disclosed the full details of what
happened there but he did say that it
was more tweaking of these hyper
parameters and optimizing that a bit so
that was 2013 winner in 2014 we saw a
slightly bigger
to this so one of the networks that was
introduced then was a vgg net from Karen
Simonian and andrew zisserman what's
beautiful about vgg net and they
explored a few architectures here and
the one that ended up working best was
this D column which is what I'm
highlighting it was beautiful about the
vgg net is that it's so simple so you
might have noticed in these previous in
these previous networks you have these
different filter sizes different layers
and you do different amount of strides
and everything kind of looks a bit hairy
and you're not sure where these hyper
parameters are coming from VG's unit is
extremely uniform all you do is 3x3
convolutions with stride one pad one and
you do two by two Macs Bowling's with
stride two and you do this throughout
completely homogeneous architecture and
you just alternate a few columns and a
few pool layers and you get top top
performance so they managed to reduce
the air down to 7.3% in the vdg net just
with a very simple item Oh genius
architecture
so it's I've also here written out this
a D architecture it's just so you can
see I'm not I'm not sure how instructed
this is because it's kind of dense but
you can definitely see and you can look
at this outline perhaps but you can see
how these volumes develop and you can
see the kinds of sizes of these filters
so they're always three by three but the
number of filters again grows so we
started off with 64 and then we go to
128 256 512 so we're just doubling it
over time I also have a few numbers here
just to give you an idea of the scale at
which these networks normally operate so
we have on the order 140 million
parameters this is actually quite a lot
I'll show you in a bit that this can be
about five or ten million parameters and
works just as well and it's about
hundred megabytes for image in terms of
memory in the forward pass and then the
backward pass also needs roughly on that
order so that's roughly the numbers that
were we're working with here also you
can note that most of the and this is
true mostly in convolutional networks is
that most of the memory is in the early
convolutional layers most of the
parameters at least in the case where
you use these giant fully connected
layers at the top would be here so the
winner actually in 2014 was not the VG
net I only present it because it's such
a simple architecture but the winner was
actually Google net with a slightly
hairier architecture we should say so
it's still a sequence of things but in
this case they've put inception modules
in sequence and this is an example
inception module I don't know
then too much time to go into the
details but you can see that it consists
basically of convolutions and different
kinds of strides and so on so the Google
net is look slightly a hairier but it
turns out to be more efficient in
several respects so for example it works
a bit better than vgg net at least at
the time it only has 5 million
parameters compared to VG nets 140
million parameters so a huge reduction
and you do that by the way by just
throwing away fully connected layers so
you'll notice in this breakdown I did
these poly connected layers here have
100 million parameters and 16 million
parameters turns out you don't actually
need that so if you take them away that
actually doesn't hurt the performance
too much so you can get a huge reduction
of parameters and it was it was slightly
we can also compare to the original
Alex net so compared to the original
Alex net we have fewer parameters a bit
more compute and a much better
performance so Google net was really
optimized to have a low footprint both
memory wise both computation wise and
both parameter wise but it looks a bit
uglier and VG net is a very beautiful
homogeneous architecture but there are
some inefficiencies in it okay so that's
a 2014 now in 2015 we had a slightly
bigger Delta on top of the architectures
so right now these architectures if you
on laocoon looked at them maybe in 1998
he would still recognize everything so
everything looks very like simple you've
just played with had parameters so one
of the first kind of bigger departures I
would argue was in 2015 with the
introduction of residual networks and so
this has worked from kamini Hey and
colleagues in Microsoft Research Asia
and so they did not only win the image
net challenge in 2015 but they want a
whole bunch of challenges and this was
all just by applying these residual
networks that were trained on image net
and then fine-tuned on all these
different tasks and you basically can
crush lots of different tasks whenever
you get a new awesome Kombat so at this
time the performance was basically 3.5
7% from these residual networks so this
is 2015 also this paper try to argue
that if you look at the number of layers
it goes up and then it
they made the point that with residual
networks as well see in a bit you can
introduce many more layers and they and
that that correlates strongly with
performance we've since found that in
fact you can make these residual
works quite shop quite a lot shallower
like say on the order of 20 or 30 layers
and they work just as fine just as well
so it's not necessarily the depth here
but I'll go into that in a bit
but you get a much better performance
what's interesting about this paper is
this this plot here where they compare
these residual networks and I'll go into
details of how they work in a bit and
these what they call plane networks
which is everything I've explained until
now and the problem with plane networks
is that when you try to scale them up
and introduce additional layers they
don't get monotonically better so if you
take a 20 layer model and on this is on
C far ten experiments if you take a 20
layer model and you run it and then you
take a 56 layer model you'll see that
the 56 layer model performs worse and
this is not just on the test data so
it's not just an overfitting issue this
is on the training data the 56 layer
model performs worse on the training
data than the 20 layer model even though
the 56 layer model can imitate 20 layer
model by setting 36 layers to compute
identities so basically it's an
optimization problem that you can't find
the solution once your problem size
grows that much bigger in this plane net
architecture so in the residual networks
that they proposed they found that when
you wire them up in a slightly different
way you monotonically get a better
performance as you add more layers so
more layers always strictly better and
you don't run into these optimization
issues so comparing residual networks to
plane networks in plane networks as I've
explained already you have this sequence
of convolutional layers where every
convolutional layer operates over volume
before and produces volume in residual
networks we have this first
convolutional layer on top of the raw
image then there's a pooling layer so at
this point we've reduced to 56 by 56 by
64 the original image and then from here
on they have these residual blocks with
these funny skipped connections and this
turns out to be quite important so let
me show you what these look like
so the original climbing paper had this
architecture here shown under original
so on the left you see original residual
networks design since then they had an
additional paper that played with the
architecture and found that there's a
better arrangement of layers inside this
block that works better empirically and
so the way this works so concentrate on
the proposed one in the middle since
that works so well
you have this pathway where you have
this representation of the image X and
then instead of transforming that
representation X to get a new X to plug
in later we end up having this X we go
off and we do some compute on the side
so that's that residual block doing some
computation and then you add your result
on top of X so you have this addition
operation here going to the next
residual block so you have this X and
you always compute deltas to it and I
think this it's not intuitive that this
should work much better or why that
works much better I think it becomes a
bit more intuitively clear if you
actually understand the backpropagation
dynamics and how backprop works and this
is why I always urge people also to
implement back rub themselves to get an
intuition for how it works what it's
computing and so on because if you
understand back rub you'll see that
addition operation is a gradient
distributor so you get a gradient from
the top and this gradient will flow
equally to all the children that
participated in that addition so you
have gradient flowing here from the
supervision so you have supervision at
the very bottom here in this diagram and
it kind of flows upwards and it flows
through these residual blocks and then
gets added to this stream and so you end
up with but this addition distributes
that gradient always identically through
so what you end up with is this kind of
a gradient superhighway as I like to
call it where these gradients from your
supervision go directly to the original
convolutional layer and then on top of
that you get these deltas from all the
residual blocks so these block can come
on online and can help out that original
stream of information this is also
related to I think why LST MS along
short-term memory networks work better
than recurrent neural networks because
they also have these kind of additional
addition operations in the lsdm and it
just makes the gradients flow
significantly better then there were
some results on top of residual networks
that I thought were quite amusing
so recently for example we had this
result on deep networks with stochastic
depth the idea here was that the authors
of this paper noticed that you have
these residual blocks that compute
Delta's on top of your string and you
can basically randomly throw out layers
so you have these say hundred blocks 100
residual box and you can randomly drop
them out and at test time similar to
drop out you introduce all of them and
they all work at the same time but you
have to scale things and it just like
with dropout
but basically it's kind of a unintuitive
result because you can throw out layers
at random and I think it breaks the
original notion of what we had of
commnets of as like these these feature
transformers we compute more and more
complex features over time or something
like that and I think it seems much more
intuitive to think about these residual
networks at least to me as some kinds of
dynamical systems where you have this
original representation of the image X
and then every single residual block is
kind of like a vector field that because
it computes in a delta on top of your
signal and so these vector fields nudge
your original representation X towards a
space where you can decode the answer Y
of like the class of that X and so if
you drop off some of these residual
blocks at random then if you haven't
applied one of these vector fields then
the other vector fields that come later
can kind of make up for it and they
nudge they basically nudge the they pick
up the slack and they nudge along
anyways and so that's possibly why this
the image I currently have in mind of
how these things work so much more like
dynamical systems in fact another
experiments that people are playing with
that I also find interesting is you
don't have you can share these residual
blocks so it starts to look more like a
recurrent neural network so these
residual blocks would have shared
connectivity and then you have this
dynamical system really where you're
just running a single RNN a single
vector field did you keep iterating over
and over and then your fixed point gives
you the answer so it's kind of
interesting what's happening
it looks very funny ok we've had many
more interesting results that so people
are playing a lot with these residual
networks and improving on them in
various ways so as I mentioned already
it turns out that you can make these
residual networks much shallower and
make them wider so you introduce more
channels and that can work just as well
if not better so it's not necessarily
the depth that is giving you a lot of
the performance it's you can scale down
the depth and if you increase the width
that can actually work better and
they're also more efficient if you do it
that way there's more funny
regularization techniques here swap-out
is a funny regularization technique that
actually interpolates between plane nets
rez nets and dropout so that's also a
funny paper with fractal nets we
actually have many more different types
of nets and so people have really
experimented with this a lot I'm really
eager to see what the winning
we'll be in 2016 as a result of a lot of
this one of the things that has really
enabled this rapid experimentation in
the community is that somehow we've
developed luckily this culture of
sharing a lot of code among ourselves so
for example Facebook has released just
as an example Facebook has released
residual networks code and torch that is
really good that a lot of these papers I
believe have adopted and worked on top
of and that allowed them to actually
really scale up their experiments and
and it explore different architectures
so it's great that this has happened
unfortunately a lot of these papers are
come kind of on archive and it's kind of
a chaos as these are being uploaded so
at this point I think this is a natural
point to plug very briefly in my archive
sanity calm so this is the best website
ever and what it does is it crawls
archive and it takes all the papers and
it analyzes all the papers the full-text
of the papers and creates tf-idf
bag-of-words features for all the papers
and then you can do things like you can
search a particular paper like residual
networks paper here and you can look for
similar papers on archive and so this is
a sorted list of basically all the
residual networks papers that are most
related to that paper or you can also
create user accounts and you can create
a library of papers that you like and
then archive Sanofi will train a support
vector machine for you and basically you
can look at what our archive papers over
the last month that I would enjoy the
most and that's just computed by archive
sanity and so it's like a curated feed
specifically for you so I use this quite
a bit and I find it in useful so I hope
that other people do as well okay so we
saw convolutional neural networks I
explained how they work I explained some
of the background context I've given you
an idea of what they look like in
practice and we went through case
studies of the winning architectures
over time but so far we've only looked
at image classification specifically so
we're categorizing images into some
number of bins so I'd like to briefly
talk about addressing other tasks in
computer vision and how you might go
about doing that
so the way to think about doing other
tasks in computer vision is that really
what we have is you can think of this
computational convolutional neural
network as this block of compute that
has a few million parameters in it and
it can do basically arbitrary functions
that are very nice over images and so
takes an image gives you some kind of
features and now different tasks will
basically look as follows you want to
picked some kind of a thing and
different tasks there will be different
things and you always have a desired
thing and then you want to make the
predicted thing much more closer to the
desired thing and you back propagate so
this is the only part usually that
changes from task to task you'll see
that these comments don't change too
much what changes is your last function
at the very end and that's what actually
helps you really transfer a lot of these
winning architectures they usually use
these pre trained networks and you don't
worry too much about the details of that
architecture because you're only worried
about you know adding a small piece at
the top or changing the last function or
substituting a new data set and so on so
just to make this slightly more concrete
in image classification we apply this
compute block we get these features and
then if I want to do classification I
would basically predict 1,000 numbers
that give me the LOC probabilities of
different classes and then I have a
predicted thing a desired thing
particular class and I can back prop if
I'm doing image captioning the it also
looks very similar instead of predicting
just a vector of 1,000 numbers I now
have for example at ten thousand ten
thousand words in some kind of
vocabulary and I'd be predicting ten
thousand numbers and a sequence of them
and so I can use a recurrent neural
network which you will hear much more
about I think in Richards lecture just
after this and so I produce a sequence
of ten thousand dimensional vectors and
that's just a description and they
indicate the probabilities of different
words to be emitted at different time
steps or for example if you want to do
localization again most of the block
stays unchanged but now we also want
some kind of a extent in the image so
suppose we want to classify we don't
only just want to classify this as an
airplane but we want to localize it with
X Y width height bounding box
coordinates and if we make a specific
assumption as well that there's always a
single one thing in the image like a
single airplane in every image then you
can just afford to just predict that so
we predict these softmax scores just
like before and apply the cross-entropy
loss and then we can predict X Y width
height on top of that and we use alloc
and l2 loss or a Hooper loss or
something like that so you just have a
predicted thing a desired thing and you
just back drop if you want to do
reinforcement learning because you want
to play different games then again the
setup is you just predict some different
thing and it has some different
semantics so in this case we will be for
example predicting eight numbers that
give us the probabilities of taking
different actions for example there are
eight discrete actions in Atari then we
just predict eight numbers and then
we trained us with a slightly different
manner because in the case of
reinforcement learning you don't
actually have a you don't actually know
what the correct action is to take at
any point in time but you can still get
a desired thing eventually because you
just run these rollouts over time and
you just see what what happens and then
that helps you that helps inform exactly
what the correct answer should have been
or what the desired thing should have
been in any one of those rollouts in any
point in time I don't want to dwell on
this too much in this lecture though
it's outside of the scope you'll hear
much more about reinforcement learning
in the in a later lecture if you wanted
to do segmentation for example then you
don't want to predict a single vector of
numbers for a single for single image
but every single pixel has its own
category that you'd like to predict so
data set will actually be colored like
this and you have different classes
different areas and then instead of
predicting a single vector of classes
you predict an entire array of 224 by
224 since that's the extent of the
original image for example times 20 if
you have 20 different classes and then
you basically have 2 24 by 2 24
independent soft maxes here that's one
way you could pose this and then you
back propagate this would here would be
slightly more difficult because you see
here I have a decom players mentioned
here and I didn't explain the
convolutional layers they're related to
convolutional layers they do a very
similar operation but kind of backwards
in some way so a compilation layer kind
of does these down sampling operations
as it computes a decon layer does these
kind of up sampling operations as it
computes these convolutions but in fact
you can implement a decomp layer using
accomplish so what you do is you decom
forward pass is the cobbler backward
pass and the decom backward pass is the
complex basically so they're basically
an identical operation but just are you
up sampling we're down sampling kind of
so you can use decomp layers or you can
use hyper columns and there are
different things that people do in
segmentation literature but that's just
the rough idea as you're just changing
to loss function at the end if you
wanted to do auto-encoders so you want
to do some surprise landing or something
like that well you're just trying to
predict the original image so you're
trying to get the convolutional network
to implement the identity transformation
and the trick of course it makes it
non-trivial is that you're forcing the
representation to go through this
representational bottleneck of 7 by 7 by
512 so the network must find an
efficient represent
of the original image so that it can
decode it later so that would be a auto
encoder you again have an l2 loss at the
end and your backdrop or if you want to
do variational auto-encoders you have to
introduce a repair motorisation layer
and you have to append an additional
small loss that makes your posterior
beer prior but it's just like an
additional layer and then you have an
entire generative model and you can
actually like sample images as well if
you wanted to do detection things get a
little more hairy perhaps a compared to
localization or something like that so
one of my favorite detectors perhaps to
explain as the yellow detector because
it's perhaps the simplest one it doesn't
work the best but it's the simplest one
to explain and has the core idea of how
people do detection in computer vision
and so the way this works is we reduced
the original image to a seven by seven
by 512 feature so really there are these
49 discrete locations that we have and
at every single one of these 49
locations we're going to predict in
yellow we're going to predict a class so
that's shown here on the top right so
every single one of these forty-nine
will be some kind of a soft Max and then
additionally at every single position
we're going to predict some number of
bounding boxes and so there's going to
be a B number of bounding boxes say B is
10 so we're going to be predicting 50
numbers and the the 5 comes from the
fact that every bounding box will have
five numbers associated with it so you
have to describe the XY the width and
the height and you have to also indicate
some kind of a confidence of that
bounding box so that's the fifth number
is some kind of a confidence measure so
you basically end up predicting these
bounding boxes they have positions they
have class they have confidence and then
you have some true bounding boxes in the
image so you know that there are certain
true boxes and they have certain class
and what you do then is you match up the
desired thing with the predicted thing
and whatever so say for example you had
one bounding box of a cat then you would
find the closest predicted bounding box
and you would mark it as a positive and
you would try to make that associated
grid cell predict cat and you would
nudge the prediction to be slightly more
towards the cat the box and so all this
can be done with simple losses and you
just back propagate that and then you
have a detector or if you want to get
much more fancy you you could do dense
image captioning so in this case this is
a combination of detection
and image captioning this is a paper
with my equal quality in Johnson and
Feifei Lee from last year and so what we
did here is image comes in and it
becomes much more complex
I don't maybe want to go into it as much
but the first order approximation is
that instead it's basically a detection
but instead of predicting fixed classes
we instead predict a sequence of words
so we use a recurrent neural network
there but basically I can take an image
then and you can predict you can both
detect and predict and describe
everything in a complex visual scene so
that's just some overview of different
tasks that people care about most of
them consist of just changing this top
part you put different loss function a
different data set but you'll see that
this computational block stays
relatively unchanged from time to time
and that's why as I mentioned when you
do transfer learning you just want to
kind of take these blue train networks
and you mostly want to use whatever
works well on imagenet because a lot of
that does not change too much okay so in
the last part of the talk I'd like to
just make sure we're good on time okay
we're good so in the last part of the
talk I just wanted to give some hints of
some practical considerations when you
want to apply convolutional net works in
practice
so first consideration you might have if
you want to run these networks is what
hardware do I use so some of the options
that I think are available to you well
first of all you can just buy a machine
so for example and Vidya has these
digits dev boxes that you can buy
they have Titan X GPUs which are strong
GPUs you can also if you're much more
ambitious you can buy dgx one which has
the newest Pascal P 100 GPS
unfortunately the dgx one is about a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars so
this is kind of an expensive
supercomputer but the digits death box I
think is more accessible and so that's
one option we can go with alternatively
you can look at the specs of a dev box
and those specs are there good specs and
then you can buy all the components
yourself and assemble it like Lego
unfortunately you that's prone to
mistakes of course but you can
definitely reduce the price maybe by
fracture like to it compared to the
Nvidia machine but of course Nvidia
machine would just come with all the
software installed all the hardware is
ready and you can just do work there are
a few GPU offerings in the cloud but
unfortunately it's actually not at a
good place right now it's actually quite
difficult to get GPUs in the cloud good
GPUs at least so Amazon AWS has these
great k5
five 20s they're not very good GPUs
they're not fast they don't have too
much memory it's actually kind of a
problem Microsoft Azure is coming up
Azura is coming up with its own offering
soon so I think they've announced it and
it's in some kind of a beta stage if I
remember correctly and so those are
powerful GPUs K 80s that would be
available to at open the eye for example
you use Sarah scale so seer scale is
much more a slightly different model you
can't spin up GPUs on demand but they
allow you to rent a box in the cloud so
what that amounts to is that we have
these boxes somewhere in the cloud I
have just the DNA I just have the URL is
sh2 it it's a it's a Titan X boxes in
the machine and so you can just do work
that way so these options are available
to hardware wise in terms of software
there are many different frameworks of
course that you could use for deep
learning so these are some of the more
common ones that you might see in
practice so different people have
different recommendations on this I
would my personal recommendation right
now to most people if you just want to
apply this in practical settings 90% of
the use cases are probably addressable
with things like Harris so Karis would I
go to number one thing to look at Karis
is a layer over tensorflow or Theano and
basically just a higher-level
API over either of those so for example
I usually use Karis on top of tensorflow
and it's a much more higher level
language than raw tensorflow
so you can also work in raw tensorflow
but you'll have to do a lot of low level
stuff if you need all that freedom then
that's great because that allows you to
have much more freedom in terms of how
you design everything but it can be
slightly more worthy for example you
have to assign every single weight you
have to assign a name stuff like that
and so it's just much more wordy but you
can work at that level or for most
applications I think Karis would be
sufficient and I've used torch for a
long time I still really like torch it's
very lightweight interpretable it works
just just fine
so those are the options that I would
currently consider at least another
practical consideration you might be
wondering what architecture what
architecture do I use in my problem so
my answer here and I've already hinted
at this is don't be a hero don't go
crazy don't design your own neural
networks and convolutional layers and
don't probably don't you don't
to do that probably so the algorithm is
actually very simple look at whatever is
currently the latest released thing that
works really well in iOS VRC you
download that pre-trained model and then
you potentially add or delete some
layers on top because you want to do
some other tasks so that usually
requires some tinkering at the top or
something like that and then you
fine-tune it on your application so
actually a very straightforward process
the first degree I think to most
applications would be don't tinker with
it too much you're going to break it but
of course you can also take two 2:31 end
and then you might become much better at
at tinkering with these architectures
second is how do I choose the parameters
and my answer here again would be don't
be a hero look into papers look what
happens they use for the most part
you'll see that all papers use the same
hyper parameters they look very similar
so Adam when you add them for
optimization it's always learning rate
one in negative three or one integrate
four so four you can also use sed
momentum it's always the similar kinds
of learning rates so don't go too crazy
designing this one of the things you
probably want to play with the most is
the regularization so and in particular
not the l2 regularization but the
dropout rates is something I would
advise instead and so because you might
have it smaller or a much larger data
set if you have a much smaller data set
and overfitting is a concern so you want
to make sure that you regular eyes
properly with dropout and then you might
want to as a second degree consideration
may be the learning rate you want to
tune that a tiny bit but that yeah
that's usually doesn't as much of an
effect so really there's like two hyper
parameters and you take a pre train
network and this is 90% of the use cases
I would say yeah so compared to when
computer version 2011 where you might
have hundreds of high parameters so yeah
okay and in terms of distributed
training so if you want to work at scale
because if you want to Train imagenet or
some large scale data sets you might
want to train across multiple GPUs so
just to give an idea
most of these state-of-the-art networks
are trained on the order of a few weeks
across multiple GPUs usually four or
eight GPUs and these GPS are roughly on
the order of one thousand dollars each
but then you also have to house them so
of course that has a different price but
you almost always want to train on
multiple GPUs if possible usually you
don't end up training across machines
that's
much more rare I think to train across
machines what's much more common is you
have a single machine and it has eight
Titan exes or something like that and
you do distributor training on those
eight titan axis there are different
ways to distribute a training so if
you're very if you're feeling fancy you
can try to do some model parallelism
where you split your network across
multiple GPUs I would instead advise
some kind of a data parallelism
architecture so usually what you see in
practice is you have a GPUs so I take my
batch of 256 images or something like
that I split it and I split it equally
across the GPUs I do forward pass on
those GPUs and then I basically just add
up all the gradients and I propagate
that through
so you're just distributing this batch
and you're doing mathematical you're
doing the exact same thing as if you had
a giant GPU but you're just splitting up
that batch across different GPUs but
you're still doing synchronous training
with SGD as normal so that's what you'll
see most in practice which i think is
the best thing to do right now for most
normal applications and other kind of
considerations that sometimes enter that
you could may be worried about is that
there are these bottlenecks to be aware
of some particular CPU to disk
bottleneck this means that you have a
giant data set it's somewhere on some
disk you want that disk to probably be
an SSD because you want this loading to
be quick because these GPUs process data
very quickly and that might actually be
a Balan like like loading the data could
be a bomb like so many applications you
might want to pre process your data make
sure that it's read out contiguously and
very raw form from something like an HD
f5 file or some kind of other binary
format and another bottleneck to be
aware of is the CPU GPU bottleneck so
the GPU is doing a lot of heavy lifting
of the neural network and the CPU is
loading the data and you might want to
use things like prefetching threads
where the CPU while the networks are
doing forward backward on the GPU your
CPU is busy loading the data from the
disk and maybe doing some pre-processing
and making sure that it can ship it off
to the GPU at the next time step so
those are some of the practical
considerations I could come up with for
this lecture if you wanted to learn much
more about convolutional neural networks
and a lot of what I've been talking
about then I encourage you to check out
CS 231 n we have lecture videos
available we have notes slides and
assignments everything is up and
available so you're welcome to check it
out and that's it thank you
so I guess I can take some questions
yeah
hello hello hi I'm Kyle afar from Luna
I'm using a lot of convolutional nets
for genomics when the problems that we
see is that our genomic sequence tends
to be arbitrary length so right now
we're pattern for a lot of zeros but
we're curious as to what your thoughts
are on using CN NS for things of
arbitrary size where we can't just down
sample to 277 by 277 yep
so is this lecture genomic sequence of
like a TCG like that kind of sequence
exactly yeah so some of the options
would be so recurrent neural networks
might be a good fit because they allow
arbitrarily sized contexts another
option I would say is if you look at the
wave net paper from deep mind they have
audio and they're using convolutional
networks for processing it and I would
basically adopt that kind of an
architecture they have this clever way
of doing what's called a truce or
dilated convolutions and so that allows
you to capture a lot of context with few
layers and so let's call dilated
convolutions and the wavelet paper has
some details and there's an efficient
implementation of it that you should be
aware of on github and so you might be
able to just drag and drop the fast wave
net code into that application and so
you have much larger context but it's of
course not infinite context as you might
have with a recurrent Network yeah we're
definitely checking those out we also
tried our n ends they're quite slow for
these things our main problems that the
genes can be very short or very long but
the whole sequence matters so I think
that's one of the challenges that we're
looking at with this type of problem
interesting yeah so those would be the
two options that I would play with
basically I think those are the two demo
where thank you
thanks for a great lecture so my
question is that is there a clear
mathematical or conceptual understanding
when people decide how many hidden
layers have to be part of their
architecture yeah so the answer with a
lot of this is there a mathematical
understanding will likely be no because
we are in very early phases of just
doing a lot of empirical and I'll guess
and check kind of work and so theory is
in some some ways like lagging behind a
bit I would say that was residual
networks you want to have more layers
usually works better and so you can take
these layers outdoor you can put them in
and it's just mostly computational
consideration of how much can you fit in
so our consideration is usually is you
have a GPU it has maybe 16 gigs of ram
or 12 gigs of ram or something
I want certain batch size and I have
these considerations and that upper
bounds the amount of like layers or how
big they could be and so I use the
biggest thing that fits in my GPU and
that's mostly what the way you choose
this and then you regularize it very
strongly so if you have a very small
data set then you might end up with a
pretty big Network for your data set so
you might want to make sure that you are
tuning those dropout rates properly and
so you're not overfitting I have
question my understanding is that the
recent convolution that doesn't use
polling layers right so the question is
why you know why don't they use fungal
areas so you know is there still a place
for puli yeah yeah so certainly so if
you saw for example the residual Network
at the end there was a single pooling
layer at the very beginning but mostly
they went away you're right so took her
I wonder if I can find the slide I
wonder if this is a good idea to try to
find the slide that's bro okay let me
just find this okay so this was the
residual network architecture so you see
that they do a first comm and then
there's a single pool right there but
certainly the trend has been to throw
them away over time and there's a paper
also
it's called striving for simplicity the
all convolutional neural network and the
point in that paper is look you can
actually do stranded convolutions you
can throw away pulling layers all
together or it's just as well so pulling
layers are kind of I would say this kind
of a bit of a historical vestige of they
needed things to be efficient then they
need to control
Bastian downsample things quite a lot
and so we're kind of throwing them away
over time and yeah they're not doing
anything like super useful they're doing
this fixed operation and you want to
learn as much as possible so maybe you
don't actually want to get rid of that
information so it's always more
appealing to it's probably more
appealing I would say to throw them away
well you mentioned there is a sort of
cognitive or brain analogy that the
brain is doing polling so yeah so I
think that analogy is stretched by a lot
so the brain I'm not sure every brain is
doing pulling yeah about image
compression not for justification about
the usage of neural networks for image
compression do we have any examples
sorry I couldn't hear the question it's
of classification for images can we use
the neural networks for image
compression image compression yeah I
think there's actually a really exciting
work in this area so one that I'm aware
of for example as a recent work from
Google where they're using commercial
networks and recurrent networks to come
up with variably sized codes for images
so certainly a lot of these generative
models I mean they are very related to
compression so definitely a lot of work
in the area of them that I'm excited
about also for example super resolution
networks so you saw the recent
acquisition of magic pony by Twitter so
they were also doing something that
basically allows you to compress you can
send low resolution strings because you
can up sample it on the client and so a
lot of work in that area yeah I had we
should patent it after you I can't
please comment on scalability regarding
number of classes so what does it take
if we go up to 10,000 or 100,000 classes
hmm yes so if you have a lot of classes
then of course you can grow your softmax
but that becomes inefficient at some
point because you're doing a giant
matrix multiply so some of the ways that
people are addressing this in practice I
believe is you use of like hierarchical
softmax
and things like that so you you
decompose your classes into groups and
then you kind of predict one group at a
time and you kind of converge that way
so I'm not I see these papers but I
don't I'm not an expert on exactly how
this works but I do know that they are
called softmax is something that people
thing especially for example in language
models this is often used because you
have a huge amount of words and you
still need to predict them somehow so I
believe Thomas Mikhailov for example he
has some papers on using hierarchical
softmax in this context would you could
you talk a little bit about the
convolutional functions like what what
considerations you should make in
selecting the functions that are used in
the convolutional filters selecting the
functions that are used in the
convolutional filters so these filters
are just parameters right so we train
those filters they're just numbers that
we trained with backpropagation okay are
you talking about the nonlinearities
perhaps or yeah I'm just wondering about
when you're selecting those the features
or when you're getting the when you're
trying to train to just understand
different features with an image what
what are those filters actually doing
well I see you're talking about
understanding exactly what those filters
are looking for in the engine somewhat
so a lot of interesting work especially
for example so Jason your Sinskey he has
this deepest toolbox and I've shown you
that you can kind of debug it that way a
bit there's an entire lecture to
encourage you to watch in CS 231 and on
visualizing understanding accomplish all
networks so people use things like a
decom or guided or guided back
propagation or you back propagate to
image and you try to find the stimulus
that maximally activates any arbitrary
neuron so different ways of probing it
and different ways have been developed
and there's a lecture about it so I
would I would check that out
great thanks I had a question regarding
the size of fine-tuning data set for
example is there a ballpark game number
if you are trying to do classification
how many do you put you need for
fine-tuning it to your sample set so how
many how many data points do you need to
get good performance since the question
okay so so okay so this is like the most
boring answer I think because the more
the better always and it's really hard
to say actually the company you need so
usually one way one way to look at it as
one heuristic that people sometimes
follow is you look at a number of
parameters and you want the number of
examples to be on the order of number of
parameters that's one way people
sometimes break it down right for
fine-tuning because we will have an
image net model so
I was hoping that most of the things
would be taken care or there and then
you're just fine-tuning so you you might
need a lower order I say so when you're
saying fine-tuning are you finding the
whole network or you're using some of it
or just the top classifier just the top
classifier yeah so one another way to
look at it is you have some number of
parameters and you can estimate the
number of bits that you think every
parameter has and then you count the
number of bits in your data so that's
kind of like comparisons you would do
but really uh yeah I have no good answer
so the more the better and you have to
try and you have to regularize and you
have to cross validate that and you have
to see what performance you get over
time because it's to task it and then
for me to say something stronger hi I
would like to know how do you think the
Covenant will work in this rady case
like is they just a simple extension of
the 2d case oh do we need some extra
tweak about in 3d case so you're talking
specifically about say videos or some 3d
accurate talking about the image that
has the depth information oh I see so
say you have like RGB D input and things
like that
yeah so I'm not too familiar with people
do but I do know for example that people
try to have for example one thing he can
do is just treat it as a fourth Channel
or maybe you want the separate ComNet on
top of the depth channel and do some
fusion later so I don't know exactly
what the state-of-the-art in treating
that depth channel is right now so I
don't exactly how they do what I do
right now oh so maybe just one more
question just how do you think the 3d
object great condition a 3d object yeah
recognition so what is the output that
you'd like the oppo is still the class
probability but we are not treating the
2d image but the 3d representation of
the art I say so do you have a mesh or
point cloud yeah I see yeah so also not
not exactly my area for currently but so
the problem with these meshes and so on
is that there's just like a rotational
degree of freedom that I'm not sure what
people do about honestly so the yeah so
I'm actually not an expert on this so I
don't want to comment there are some
obvious things you might want to try
like you might want to plug in all the
possible ways you could orient this and
then a test time averaged over them so
there would be some of the obvious
things to play with but I don't I'm not
actually sure what the state of the art
is okay thank you
so coming back to the distributed
training is it possible to do even the
classification a distributed way or my
questions in future can I imagine my our
cellphones do these things together for
one inquiry our cellphones oh I see
you're trying to get cell phones
distributed training yes it's a train
it's arrived quite a fun very radical
idea so related thoughts I had recently
was so I had come the jas in the browser
and I was thinking of basically this
trains narrow networks and I was
thinking about similar questions because
you could imagine shipping this off as
an ad equivalent like the people just
include this in the JavaScript and then
everyone's browsers are kind of like
training a small network so I think
that's a related question do you think
there's like too much communication
overhead or it could be actually really
disturbed in an efficient way
yes so the problem with distributing it
a lot is actually a stale gradients
problem so when you look at some of the
papers that Google has put out about
distributed training as you look at the
number of workers when you do
asynchronous SGD number of workers and
the the performance improvement you get
it kind of like plateaus quite quickly
after like eight workers or something
quite small so I'm not sure if there are
ways of dealing with thousands of
workers the issue is that you have a
distributed every worker has this like
specific snapshot of the weights that
are currently I have to pull you pull
from the master and now you have a set
of ways that you're using and do forward
backward and you send an update but by
the time you send an update and you down
your forward backward the parameters
server has now done like lots of updates
from like thousands of other things and
so you're grading the scale you've
evaluated it every wrong an old location
and so it's an incorrect direction now
and everything breaks so that's the
challenge and I'm not sure what people
are doing about this yeah I was
wondering about applications of
convolutional nets to two inputs at a
time so let's say you have two pictures
of jigsaw puzzles puzzles
these are pieces they're trying to
figure out if they fit together or
whether one object compares to the other
in a specific way have you heard of any
implementation of this kind yes so you
have two inputs instead of one yeah so
the common way
dealing with that as you put a comment
on each and then you do some kind of a
fusion eventually to to merge the
information right I see and same for
recurrent neural networks if you have
like variable input so for example in
the context the videos where you have
frames coming in yeah then yeah so some
of the approaches are you have
accomplished all Network on the frame
and then at the top you tie it in with
the recurrent neural network so you have
these you reduce the image to some kind
of a lower dimensional representation
and then that get that's an input to a
recurrent neural network at the top
there are other ways to play with this
for example you can actually make the
recurrent you can make every single
neuron in the calm that recurrent that's
also one funny way of doing this so
right now when a neuron computes its
output it's only a function of a local
neighborhood and below it but you can
also make it in addition a function of
that same local neighborhood or like its
own activation perhaps in the previous
time step if that makes sense so so this
so this neuron is not just computing a
dot product with the with the current
patch but it's also incorporating a dot
product of its own and maybe it's
neighborhoods activations at the
previous time step of the frame so
that's kind of like a small or an update
hidden inside every single neuron so
those are the things that I think people
play with when I'm not familiar with
what currently is working best in this
area pretty awesome thank you yeah yeah
thanks for the great talk
final question regarding the latency for
the models that are trained using
multiple layers so especially at the
prediction time you know as we add more
more layers for the forward pass it will
take some time you know it'll increase
in the latency right for the prediction
so what are the numbers that we have
seen you know you know presently that
you know that you know if you can share
that you know the prediction time or the
you know the latency at the the forward
pass so you're worried for example
you're some you want to run a friction
very quickly would it be on an embedded
device or is this in the cloud uh you're
suppose you know it's a cell phone you
know you have your you know identifying
the objects or you know you're you're
doing some you know image analysis or
something yeah so there's definitely a
lot of work on this so one way you would
approach this actually is you have this
network that you've trained using
floating point arithmetic 32 bits say
and so there's a lot of work on taking
that Network and
discretizing all
into like intz and making it much
smaller and pruning connections so one
of the works I'm related to this for
example is someone here at Stanford has
few papers on getting rid of spurious
connections and reducing the network as
much as possible and then making
everything very efficient with integer
arithmetic so basically you achieve this
by discretizing all the weights and all
the activations and throwing away and
pruning the network so there are some
tricks like that that people play that's
mostly what you would do in an embedded
device and then the challenge of course
is you've changed the network and now
you just kind of are crossing your
fingers that it works well and so I
think what's interesting for Reese from
research standpoint is he'd like to do
you'd like your test time to exactly
match your training time right so then
you get the best performance and so the
question is how do we train with low
precision arithmetic and there's a lot
of work on this as well so say from your
show up in Joe's lab as well and so
that's exciting directions of how you
train in low precision regime do you
have any numbers I mean that you can
share for the new state of the art how
much time does it yes I see the papers
but I'm not sure if I remember the exact
reductions it's on the order of okay I
don't want to say because it's go no
thanks I don't want to try to guess this
thank you all right we're out of time
let's thank Andrew
lunch is outside and will restart at
12:45